12 insoumis seront candidats dans les
yvelines certains sont issus de la
société civile sapeurs-pompiers artisans
boulangers photographes ou encore
salarié d'une multinationale
c'est le parcours de benjamin nicoletta
candidat dans la 10e circonscription
face à une gauche divisée en 5 et au
duel déjà anticipé entre jean frédéric
poisson et aurore bergé
il veut se démarquer sur la manière de
gouverner les conférences citoyennes
qu'on voudra mettre en place aussi la
france a soumis ce gagne dans l'ensemble
de la france c'est pour faire remonter
les idées si vous voulez du terrain j'ai
moi le gg 1 les gars partent un regard
particulier avec la politique où je me
dis que les personnes qui ont réponse à
tout déjà savez quelque chose qui me
chagrine ce que je veux c'est que ça
vienne vraiment du terrain autres
circonscriptions ancré à droite est
difficile à conquérir celles de david
douillet député sortant de la 12e sur la
ligne de départ la gauche par là aussi
désunis mais la france insoumise croit
en sa qualification au second tour
je pense que si vous étiez avec moi dans
certains quartiers notamment de plaisir
et de poids si vous vous verriez qu'il
ya un engouement pour ce mouvement de la
france a souri qui est extraordinaire
première force de gauche sur la 11e
circonscription jean luc mélenchon a
totalisé près de 25% des voix lors du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017
une victoire est donc possible pour la
france insoumise malgré la présence
d'autres candidatures à gauche dont
celle du parti communiste français
c'est la proposition qu'on a adressé à
nyc miserait et aux communistes de la
circonscription
donc voilà ils ont fait le choix eux
deux décliné cette proposition de
maintenir la candidature de luc miserait
donc voilà c'est une situation qui est
fort regrettable dans les autres
circonscriptions on retrouve thibault
marshall dans la première enfin sur la
deuxième et la troisième circonscription
les candidats de la france insoumise
devront faire face à des candidatures
communes entre europe ecologie les verts
le parti socialiste et le pcf